If this video gets 5,000 retweets.
My mom is going to buy me an Xbox .
Please guys.
Can we smash 5,000 likes on this video?
And CEO of YouTube, Susan Wojcicki,
has agreed to take me to prom!
Pleaseeee guys if this video gets...
(Earrape)
10,000,000,000
Elon Musk will send me to space and leave me there.
That's right haters, no more YouTube videos
Begging for likes, it's something that we all do.
#Relatable.
Leave a like if you agree on that one.
But when does begging for likes
just become too much, too annoying?
Sometimes, I like to sneak a little
"Hey guys, did you enjoy this video?
Be sure a leave a LiKe!"
But some people just take it too far. Some people
have no integrity and they just start yelling.
1oNEjidshsakhghafghdsagfmillonlikes?
They start screaming
(Bass boost)
ArRRGHHGHGGH
And they are ANG-
It makes me ANGRIY.
What are you?
(Text-to-speech)
ｇａｙ?
(Sive puts Senfield music)
Now with the latest trend of things... I'm just gonna keep em' up here (huehue)
of begging for likes has gone- it's gone too far
You've gone two steps too far. It makes me so mad
I could snap my back into half right now.
The new trend of begging for likes has become
Can I get better grades please for retweets you may have seen this tweet it got hundred and thirty seven thousand retweets
Hundred thousand retweets and mr.
Fryer will bub my 89.2% to a ninety percent from last semester
Probably won't happen, but we'll try
We will try to get me a better grade apparently a lot of people obviously bought into this
I mean it got 137 thousand retweets
No, I'm not salty that this got more retweets than my engagement. That's not it at all. Okay. This is the dumbest shit
I've ever seen I don't know how the American school system works. I don't know how grades work
They're basically what we had at least in university was three is past and five is maximum
So you either get nothing three four or five?
And then you get a beverage from that if it works somewhat similar that she needs a 4.0. I'm sorry, but you suck
Why are so many people retweeting this and why did this teacher I?
Remember there was just no way in my school that you could even sweet talk anything about
Changing the grade if you thought the teacher could made a mistake you could bring that up and be like hey
Sorry you corrected this
But I think the injection should be like this it happened and the teacher would change it but doing it for retweets
I'm sorry, but what the hell that's the dumbest thing I've ever seen I worked so damn hard okay
So no one else should get anything for free
People shouldn't get things for free now apparently this is not the only time this has been a thing we need
24,000 retweet by June 1st, this is posted just a few weeks before we need
24,000 retweet by June for no accounting final help us
why
Why
Just take the test like everyone else why did the teacher agree to this
Yeah, you know what that's a lot of retweet
I
Suppose there will be no final who cares what you learn or not if you can get a lot of retweets on
The internet that is the most that is the most valuable source of all time
Anything else has no real importance or value
Learning things is not important as retweets how about that lesson to you kids so a lot of people started to
Try and recreate this if we can get five thousand retweets my accounting class has no final
twitter do your thing go Twitter go!
If we work together we can do anything!
No school!
Yay, oh, you got 248 that's too bad
attention Twitter
Misses Kiska calculus teacher had offers to give us three student in the picture a passing grade
If this gets 25 thousand retweets, please help us with this. Oh, No it only got 78 retweets. Oh no
They're not gonna pass their grade.
My heart bleeds for these students wearing wearing a vest and a tie
I can't even tell who is the student and who's the teacher these people are struggling in school
I've got 10 days left come on guys oh
He tweeted @Ninja
Ninja please I'm gonna--. Ninja, please. I need your help, man
Ninja why? Did you not retweet these what the Frick dude? You could have used your fortnite influence
so selfish some people oh, man
I would have easily retweeted this
Because this is just for a good cause okay everyone hate school hashtag
I hate school too leave a like on this video guys. Can we hit?
50,000 likes in school will just disappear
That's right my principal agreed upon it and if we get 1 million likes
My teacher will perform seppuku and the whole school system
And the universe will disappear the earliest example I can find of this was in in December last year. They asked for
75,000 retweets to not get their final exam in international marketing at least if the subject is marketing and you managed to get
50,000 retweets I said I can sort of understand that but just skipping your accounting exam is just like why
500,000 retweets and mr
Joseph will exempt our AP chemistry final we have until May 17 come on guys
We this is a common common thing they use to get you into the retweets. Oh I get to be part of this joke
Retweet so funny. Can you at least clean up your whiteboard?
Every single time it's all American students - is it that bad
In America are you ok America 1k retweets for the best teacher of LG to add us on snapchat?
What you couldn't even hit it?
Pathetic all right a thousand retweets. Do you know what that is to me nothing it means nothing to me?
I absolutely garbage. This is despicable this whole thing reminds me of that Indian friendship meme how great you're all- OOF!
Congratulations. Guys, my teacher said if we had
20,000 retweets he will let go of my hand can we please do it? Oh man there's stuck at
2600, damn guys can we please retweet this to stop this abuse some say they are still holding hands to this date
It's actually a very nice romantic story again. I can't tell who's the teacher and the student
What is wrong with your school. @GeraltButler my teacher mrs.
Lemke is a huge fan and says that if we can get ten thousand retweets and a lunch date with you
We will all get hundred of our English three final. Please help now. This is just sad
This is sad because I know she'll do it
It's like all those guilt guilt tweets about going to the prom
Hey
If this gets 20 thousand retweets this celebrity will have to take me to prom how many retweets for you to take my senior
Photos with me twenty five thousand and I get to wear this school sweatshirt
And hold a trombone. How meme worthy and exciting, yay
If this video gets five likes. I am going to release nude photos of my dog
Please can we make it happen everybody. @Josephstalin how many retweets for you to wear my Сука Блять merch.
Please respond come on Internet. Let's make this happen together together. We can do it yeah
Yay. @despacito how many retweets to remake it in Swedish?
Please guys if the internet works together
We can make this happen if I get five hundred thousand retweets this can happen to me
You didn't even get it. That's
$4.99 by the way pathetic at least get the right amount it's literally just to become like a marketing tool now for companies
Look how many retweets yay
I hate everything. I cannot feel joy anymore
Help me. Can we get 50 likes to help restore any form of happiness in my heart?
Please guys can we do it 500 retweets, and I'll wear the Crocs for graduation just do it
Oh you did anyway even though you didn't get 500 no one cares
Hundred retweets and I wear these babies to graduation no one cares
150 retweets and I'll just do it. I don't care the internet is not your like machine
How many retweets will it take for you to go to prom with me? 10k.
You know she's saying you're basically ugly, right? Hey look at that. I got an air kiss for ten ten thousand retweets great
Hey, David, how many retweets for me to go on a date with your mom? Twenty-five thousand should be enough, yes
I'll treat her nice. It will be a good time.
Guys. Help me get thousand retweets so I can can my awesome teacher to prom how about a thousand retweets to?
Make you learn how to spell. Can my awesome teacher. Well done. Well done. Good job
It even got a thousand almost like Jesus Christ. Help her get five thousand retweets
Through her teacher wrong how does that prove your teacher wrong if anything you can't spell
Despite having a Word document help you autocorrect
Jesus Christ
Retweet for bonus meme. Wow Brad 2, sad much
My wife said if I get 1 million like I can name our son Goku just do it
I don't care my wife boyfriend say if this post can get 500 retweets. He'll buy me a nintendo switch.
Please guys if there's one thing if we all work together. Get this man a Nintendo from his wife's boyfriend
It's for a good cause dropping my new song monday. If this gets a hundred thousand retweets thousand retweets ah
That's the thing everyone deletes them when they don't hit the goal I see you okay?
I know what you're up to. We need to shame these people Rita Ora shame on you by the way make Twitter get hacked
Somebody's threatening to release new music. I've worked really hard on that no one wants to hear
Listen it was funny. Once I get it the whole
Retweet to get Carter his nuggets. It was funny. It was memable
It was weird okay, and the fact that this tweet has more retweets than Barack Obama tweet
There's something beautiful about that, but these cringy ass kids
Just do your homework instead next time how about that and stop wasting my time. I don't want to see this thing
I don't want to hear about it. Just to stop. Thank you for watching this video if we hit 5,000 likes
I will enter this closet, and I will never come back. That's right
All we need.
5000 is too little? 500k likes
and I'll never come back.
I'll be waiting just let me know when we hit
500k okay?
Just promise to let me know, so I know when to come out. Remember to like
Jesus Christ is being held hostage in the Pentagon.